all right I'm ready to go ahead ask me
anything you know me I'm an open book
I'm insulted by the premise of that
question I haven't seen him I saw daddy
on the tape same as everyone else
[Music]
he vanished Donald Trump has been
missing since 2020 for six years now he
left he's gone he took the midnight bus
to Georgetown like the song
when was the beginning of the end well I
guess it was 2018 when the Democrats
took the house and made Alexandria
Caulfield Cortez the speaker and chair
of ways and means and oversight to
banking in foreign affairs and starting
pitcher on the softball team the new
democratic led Congress announcing their
intentions to file articles of
impeachment it was scary
everyone was talking about impeachment
because of what Cohen told them and
because of what Eric told them and
because of what I told them and because
of what Milania told them because it
would have Anka told them because of
what Jared told them this was different
than with Muller because Cortes was well
she was hot she was like Chita Rivera
with subpoena power I mean the president
got his wires crossed speaker Acacio
Cortes is a very treacherous beautiful
unamerican lovely dishonest luscious dad
was thinking with his dick and his dick
didn't work anymore
you